- So, how did you find
out about "Ms. Marvel"?
- WhatsApp.
- Is that real?
- Yeah, my aunt was part of...
- Your life right now, okay, keep going.
- Dude, it's crazy.
My aunt was part of a group
chat that she never opens.
One day she decided to, and
there was the "Ms. Marvel"
casting call, and it was a blank page.
"Ms. Marvel," send headshot
and resume to this email.
Super sketchy, so obviously I did it.
(Kelly chuckling)
But no, I was a huge "Ms.
Marvel" fan in high school.
I read all the comics.
I was a Marvel nerd.
My entire life surrounded Marvel,
and now people actually have
to listen when I talk about it,
'cause I work for it.
- Oh my God, you get paid for it now.
It's amazing.
- But yeah.
- That's awesome though,
that you always loved it, and
then you get your first role
is something that you loved as a kid.
You're still a kid to me, but yeah,
I was like, I could be your mom.
Look we can...
- Wow,
how do you get a career online?
That's amazing.
Your aunt went online.
- [Kelly] Oh, musicians do it daily, yeah.
- WhatsApp, and it was like
this is the brownest way
this could have happened.
For South Asians, WhatsApp is our home.
(all laughing)
- It's our home.
- It's Costco and Whatsapp.
- You're funny too.
(audience applauding)